how much of science progresses by
individual lone geniuses
and how much by the messi collaboration
of competing and
cooperating humans
i don't think you can cut
that
with a knife to say it's this percent
and that percent
it's
almost always the case that there are
one or two or maybe three
individuals
who
are sort of central
to what goes on when things begin to
shift
are they inevitably and solely
responsible for what then
begins to happen
um in a major way i think not
uh it depends you can go
very far back with this
uh
even into antiquity to see what goes on
um
the locus the major locus we always talk
about from the beginning is if you're
talking about galileo's work on motion
for example
were there ways of accommodating it that
others could adapt to without buying
into the whole scheme yes
did it eventually evolve and start
convincing people because you could also
do other things with it that you
couldn't otherwise do
also yes let me give you an example the
great french mathematician philosopher
descartes
who
was a mechanical philosopher he believed
the world was
matter in motion
he never thought much of what galileo
had done in respect to motion
because he thought well at best it's
some sort of approximative scheme or
something like that
but one of his
initial
i wouldn't call him a disciple but
follower who then broke with him in
number of ways was a man named christian
huygens who was along with newton one of
the two greatest
scientists of the 17th century
huygens is older than newton and huygens
nicely deployed galilean relationships
in respect to motion to develop all
sorts of things including the first
pendulum governed
clock
and even figured out how to build one
which is keeps perfect time except it
didn't work but he had the mathematical
structure for it
you